[Musique]
ce qui est important c'est dans le cadre
de la présidence française de l'union
européenne les parlements soient
associés et donc c'est une conférence
interparlementaire au sénat avec les
assemblées nationales et les sénats d'à
peu près tous les états membres qui sont
présents le sujet évidemment est
essentiel puisque c'est la souveraineté
industrielle de l'europe à un moment où
on sort d'une crise sanitaire
extrêmement pressante et on est en
pleine crise en ukraine avec une
invasion par la russie extrêmement
violente et donc exploré toutes les
dimensions de la souveraineté européenne
c'est très important l'autonomie
stratégique pour l'europe c'est la
capacité au travers des crises au
travers de sa politique de pouvoir
continuer à développer une industrie de
développer des services aux européens de
façon autonome et sans dépendre
évidemment de puissance étrangère ou
d'approvisionnement trop concentré je
crois qu'on peut dire que c'est
désormais un moment de vérité pour
l'union européenne
parce qu'il est temps de démontrer
encore plus
que nous défendons ensemble
les valeurs qui nous unissent
les valeurs de démocratie
les valeurs de solidarité
qui sont l'essence même
de notre projet européen
il ya des solutions qui ont déjà été
esquissé ces derniers mois avec la mise
en place du plan de relance avec la mise
en place des sanctions face à la viola
l'invasion russe avec un plan de
réflexion autour de la résilience de
l'union européenne il ya des solutions
de court terme qui sont en place mais il
faut évidemment réfléchir plus avant et
c'est le cadre du mandat de la
commission qui a été confirmé par le
sommet de versailles la semaine dernière
qui était beaucoup discuté aujourd'hui
sur les manières d'assurer la
souveraineté industrielle de l'europe à
la fois en terme
de d'importation de matériel de matières
premières de terreur et puis évidemment
de capacité à construire à fabriquer des
produits made in europe on a longtemps
sur notre en tout cas dans les dernières
années sur notre territoire européen
laissez un antagonisme entre la
production et la transformation
environnementale et nous voyons qu'il
est temps enfin de réconcilier la
capacité à produire et la capacité à
transformer notre modèle et moi je crois
qu'on en sort par l'innovation je pense
qu'on en sort par le progrès et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui cette réflexion là elle
est vraiment au coeur de toute la
stratégie européenne